peut-on encore manifestés sereinement en
france sans violence comment expliquer
ce phénomène récurrent quelle attitude
de la part des autorités
c'est l'objet de notre face à face ce
soir prêt pour en débattre nous sommes
avec à didier martinez secrétaire
régional syndicat unité cp police
bonsoir didier martinez merci d'être
avec nous à ses côtés pour apporter la
contradiction david guiraud porte-parole
jeunesse de la rance insoumise bonsoir
vous également david guiraud merci
d'être avec nous vous avez certainement
vu l'avis de dire aux cetc images de
violence on vous les voyez qu est ce que
vous vous dites qu'il ya un réel
problème dans notre pays bas c'est des
images terribles on a l'impression d'un
affrontement direct entre les policiers
quand on qu'on n'est pas dans le même
commun comme disait notre préfet à paris
je pense que c'est pas forcément dans
tout le pays les incidents c'est
précisément à paris et dans quelques
grandes villes
parce que quand vous regardez bien
notamment en province vous avez des
manifestations qui se passe plutôt bien
mais moi je crois qu'à paris la volonté
politique de la préfecture et du
ministère de l'intérieur de l'intérieur
c'est que ça dégénère ne dit pas qui a
pas de gens qui ne veulent pas la
violence y compris dans les cortèges de
manifestants
mais quand je constate que le
gouvernement a mobilisé plus d'agents de
police est fonctionnaire de police
contre les soignantes que contre les
tchétchènes à dijon les premiers jours
il ya un problème et ça s'est passé et
ça pour le coup c'est pas forcément de
la faute des fonctionnaires de police
c'est le gouvernement qui fait ses choix
là les mais après il ya aussi une
question de gestion et de doctrines de
maintien de l'ordre qui va pas les
images que vous avez vu les charges les
charges policières c'est n'importe quoi
c'est n'importe quoi de charger comme ça
encore longtemps sur les champs pour
interpeller une personne ça met en
danger aussi les policiers sa demande
danger les manifestants parce que du
coup les policiers sont très stressés
ils sont dans des situations extrêmement
tendu donc en a qui perdent leurs nerfs
y en a qui perdent leur qu'elle y en a
qui font des choses qu'il ne faut pas
faire de toutes ces images là elle ce
terrible avoir elles sont terribles
parce que c'est pas des images d'un pays
démocratique c'est des images de d'autre
chose que de la démocratie et ça je
pense fondamentalement que tout le monde
tout le monde je dis bien tout le monde
en parle
les soignants parce que du coup on ne
parle pas de leur mobilisation parle des
violences d'un côté comme de l'autre
comme si c'était la guerre civile les
manifestants qui pour la plupart sont
quand même des gens globalement
pacifique mais qui se prennent des gaz
lacrymogènes des coûts parfois sont
arrêtés pour rien vous savez pendant le
mouvement des gilets jaunes ya eu des
milliers de gardes à vue injustifiées et
puis les policiers qui subissent aussi
cette situation là et cette doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre qui à mon avis faut
changer rapidement
ça tombe bien on en a un avec nous en
direct didier martinez vous en tant que
policier quel est votre regard sur ces
manifestations qui effectivement quasi à
chaque fois dégénère
la faute à qui si on peut s'empêcher
parce que c'est évidemment toujours très
compliqué alors tout ne dégénère pas
déjà un aiguillon n'est pas dans une
configuration selon la ville mais
uniquement selon le comportement et le
déroulement de la manifestation
dès lors que des hostilités commencent
dès lors que des exactions sont
constatées et bien évidemment une
réponse de l'autorité donc de la force
publique a lieu
et lorsque ça dégénère et bien forcément
il faut d'une part assurer la protection
des manifestants parce qu'on voit on a
des infirmières on peut regarder chez
les gens on peut avoir des gens qui ont
un message à faire passer
et dans ces conditions les violences qui
peuvent être générées
nous devons pas leur porter préjudice
est en tout cas les policiers ont de
plus en plus de mal à contenir les
exactions de plus en plus grave les
atteintes dont ils font l'objet
parce qu'il faut le rappeler la plupart
des violences qui sont constatés leçon à
l'encontre des forces de l'ordre et là
c'est un nouveau problème qui se greffe
à beaucoup de manifestations
david biraud effectivement il ya
toujours voilà parfois un discours un
petit peu manichéen c'est la faute des
manifestants c'est la faute des
policiers de l'état
est ce que vous êtes d'accord vous de
dire qu'il ya une forme aussi de
manifestation on entendait patrice
pelloux hier se plaindre effectivement
que le message d'aidés soignants ne
passait pas parce que tout simplement il
y avait elle en lui en ce jour reprend
ses propos par les dés de l'extrême
gauche des anarchistes qui venait voilà
semer le trouble dans ces manifestations
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce
diagnostic vous mais moi je suis pas
pour la violence de toute façon je
trouve ça nul à chaque fois qu'il ya des
actes violons ça dessert totalement la
cause c'est mon avis
mais on parle plus des violences que des
revendications des gens donc je suis pas
pour faire ça maintenant il ya aussi des
moments où la volonté que ça dégénère de
la part de la préfecture de police est
manifeste
allez manifeste je prends un exemple à
revenez mois david biraud c'est
important parce qu'on vous parle est
essentiellement la préfecture de police
de paris parce que c'est souvent le
reproche qui est fait notamment au
préfet l'allemand on vise la capitale
spécifiquement oui oui parce que je
pense que le préfet l'allemand est un
homme dangereux
vraiment je pèse mes mots en disant ça
je pense que c'est quelqu'un de
dangereux pour la démocratie est
dangereux pour la santé
des manifestants comme des policiers
d'ailleurs et là dedans il ya plusieurs
choses
moi par exemple la manifestation
antiraciste de samedi à une semaine et
demi là il n'y avait aucun incident
franchement il y avait alors tellement
marginal que c'était mais pourtant vous
avez une manifestation qui est contenue
pendant trois heures en gt gt à une
manifestation dans lequel le préfet
l'allemand arrive à 12h30 il dit aux
organisateurs
ok pour manifester et à 14h30 il se
ravise et vous avez vous retrouvé serrés
comme des sardines pendant trois heures
évidemment qu'il ya des gens qui
commencent à s'énerver de la même
manière que dans la manifestation des
soignants on a vu les images de farida
cette infirmière de 50 ans qui le dit
elle même elle a craqué mais vous voyez
bien que ce n'est pas le profil type
d'un black block ou d'un casseur on ne
sait pas quoi c'est pas du tout ce
profil là c'est que à force de de faire
dégénérer des manifestations à force de
mettre un cadre policiers extrêmement
est extrêmement fort extrêmement kivu
n'assure des places oui à des tensions
et guay et et vous retrouver dans des
situations où moi j'en ai vu où des gens
non violent se mettra à se mettre par
colère parce qu'ils craquent pour plein
de raisons pas forcément d'ailleurs tout
acceptable mais se mettent à craquer et
si on veut sortir de ça il faut qu'on
accepte de ne pas mettre des dispositifs
par exemple policiers aussi immense à
paris c'est n'importe quoi moi je vous
le dis à à paris quand vous avez confié
qu'une manifestation antiraciste qui se
passe bien mais vous êtes complètement
encerclées place de la république
c'est pas normal les gens se disent quoi
ils se disent bon bah moi je vais
exercer un droit démocratique celui de
manifester un des droits à d'ailleurs
qu'en disait constitutionnel parce que
fondamental c'est j'exprime mon opinion
mais j'ai pas le droit je suis bloqué
j'ai pas le droit de faire ça gênait sur
ce qu'on vient d'entendre parce que
c'est un reproche qui est récurrent du
côté en tout cas des manifestants qui
sont souvent en essais ils le disent en
tout cas quand ils sont sur le terrain
et c'est à ce moment là effectivement
que ça souvent ça dégénère cette
stratégie justement d'opter par le
préfet de paris quelle est votre réponse
en d'une page web dire il ya des
dizaines de milliers de manifestations
tant à paris qu'en province qui se
déroule parfaitement bien
il est vrai que ces derniers temps il y
en a beaucoup qui dégénère
particulièrement à paris pourquoi il y à
un dispositif très conséquent de police
justement pour pouvoir intervenir à tout
moment selon la configuration et
l'orientation de leurs manifestations et
les violences qui peuvent survenir et
surgir et bien entendu on ne pourrait
que reprocher d'ailleurs à la préfecture
de ne pas avoir pris toutes dispositions
pour empêcher des exactions et donc le
dispositif il est parfaitement calibré à
chaque opération
et lorsque la police intervient encore
une fois lorsque la manifestation
commence à dégénérer ou qu'il y à des
information préalable donné par le
renseignement comme sur un dispositif
qui doit se déplacer qui doit être
mobile et que l'on va maintenir sur le
thème d'un rassemblement c'est parce
qu'il ya la crainte probable qu'il y ait
de la casse qu'il y ait des violences et
donc tout est à chaque fois parfaitement
justifiée et ne faut pas porter
systématiquement accusation par rapport
à l'accusation ou par rapport à
l'organisation de la manifestation où le
calibrage précisément du nombre de
forces de l'ordre parce que on le voit
tantôt elles sont dépassées par les
événements réels doivent essayer de
contenir 100 200 300 individus
extrêmement violent et déterminé
et quand tout se passe bien il peut y
avoir parfois énormément de policiers
qui n'interviennent pas qu'ils sont
totalement invisibles parce que la
manifestation se déroule sans aucune
sans aucun affrontement et sans aucune
hostilité
oui non mais c'est moi je moi je suis
pas d'accord parce que c'est tout
problème n'ya pas avoir une gestion
militaire quasiment parce que
franchement quand vous voyez des crs et
que vous êtes nez à nez avec eux vu
leurs vues leurs uniformes vu leur leur
appareillage
quand même ils sont pas astreints je
vous dis moi quand je me retrouve face à
se dire on pardonnez moi je veux pas
vous couper mais effectivement quand on
voit l'arc de triomphe qui est attaqué
comme ça l'a été en début du mouvement
d'aidé gilet jaune quel poste vous
poserons la question naïvement qu'elle
peut être la réponse justement des
forces de l'ordre et des autorités mais
sur l'arc de triomphe par exemple s'est
justifié d'intervenir moi j'ai pas dit
le contraire s'il ya des dégradations
dans l'arc de triomphe s'est justifié je
dis juste que la préfecture elle joue
des jeux et le ministère d'un terrain
joue un jeu assez étrange regardez par
exemple en ce moment quasiment tous les
soirs vous avez des policiers justement
parlé de l'arc de triomphe des policiers
en ce moment qui font des manifestations
de sauvage au niveau de l'arc de
triomphe au niveau des champs-elysées ce
sont des manifestations sauvages qui
devrait être interdite
eh ben c'est toléré voilà c'est toléré
parce que la démocratie c'est pas juste
regarder un texte de loi en se disant à
ses interdits faut absolument réprimer
tout le monde et leur mettre des coups
de bâton vous avez des manifestations
sauvages dans le pays
ça arrive parce que des fois les gens
n'ont pas le temps de déclarer je vous
rappelle que ces trois jours pour
déclarer une manifestation mais quand
vous avez je sais pas quelque chose qui
vous choque un mort ou quelque chose
d'autre vous pouvez pas respecté ce
délai de trois jours et bâloise dit est
ce que je dénonce c'est cette hypocrisie
qui consiste à autoriser par exemple une
manifestation sauvage de policiers
quasiment tous les soirs depuis quelques
jours mais quand sur des manifestations
anti racistes qui se passe ça était
justement toléré par le ministère de
l'intérieur alors qu'on est en crise
sanitaire avec les rassemblements de
plus de 10 personnes justement ce au nom
de l'émotion messieurs pour terminer
leur donnez moi je voulais vous faire
réagir sur les propos de manuel valls
interrogé par le magazine valeurs
actuelles l'ancien premier ministre a
livré son analyse sur l'objectif
poursuivi justement par certains
manifestants
ils ciblent écoutez plutôt que de
s'attaquer à cette réalité ces
mouvements cherche à enrôler des jeunes
désocialisés les instrumentaliser pour
créer le désordre
cette logique de la victimisation est
renforcée grâce aux liens entre le
mouvement et redit génisses tu es une
partie de la gauche le npa des
écologistes une frange de la france est
soumise
du pc voit une minorité du parti
socialiste la lutte des classes
disparaît au profit de l'affrontement de
la guerre entre races profit de
l'affrontement de la guerre entre arras
avant de vous faire réagir david dire ou
parce que vous n'êtes pas
personnellement visé mais votre
mouvement en tout cas là la france
insoumise je vais quand même donner eux
également la parole à didier martinez
est ce que ce diagnostic de manuel valls
ou le partager aujourd'hui la guerre des
races bah écoutez moi je m'en tiendrais
au constat est certainement pas
l'analyse politique de monsieur valls
pour revenir sur les propos de monsieur
giraud je précise que l'apparence des
forces de l'ordre et leur équipement
je pense que force est de constater que
ça m'impressionne ne pas vraiment grand
monde et surtout pas les centaines
d'individus qui veulent en découdre qui
viennent se battre avec eux et qui
viennent un pour vraiment tout pour
casser tout détruire sur les sites de
manifestations dont je crois que là on
est vraiment sur un faux débat et que ce
n'est certainement pas par cet angle
d'attaqué de désarmer la police
d'enlever tous les moyens au contraire
de préserver autant que faire se peut la
paix publique et le bon déroulement
d'une manifestation je croyais vraiment
d'autres angles d'attaqué celui-là ça
c'était pour la réponse d'avant david
guiraud sur voilà les propos de manuel
valls qui vise clairement la france
insoumise quelle est votre réponse
- manuel valls je m'en souviens bien
parce que c'était mais pour les
premières manifestations où j'étais
organisateurs quand j'étais dans la
jeunesse le bilan de manuel valls et aux
manifestations vous savez cette doctrine
cas consiste à rapprocher les crs très
près des cordons de manifestants ce qui
fait qu'ils avaient beaucoup
d'affrontements parce que ça gênait avec
énormément de tension vous avez un crs
en face de vous vous ne voyez pas mais
moi je vous le dis quand j'ai un crs en
face de moi je me sens pas forcément à
l'aise et encore ça va mais pour
beaucoup de jeunes manifestants
dansaient une image vraiment qu'ils qui
n'inspire pas la confiance je vous le
dis c'est quand vous avez des gens
habillés en tenue de robocop bon bah
c'est peut-être leur accoutrement mais
ça n'inspire pas en tout cas pas la
sérénité
parce que c'est quand même des gens avec
un arsenal quasiment militaire qu en
face de vous alors que vous quand vous
êtes dans votre première manifestation
et que vous êtes jeune vous dîtes juste
aux pages à exercer mes droits je vais
pas faire la guerre mais bon ça c'est un
autre débat mais sur voila moi le bilan
le bilan de valls je vous le dis c'est
sûr on justement la question de cette
guerre des races la victimisation quand
il dit voilà npa
la france a soumis sont d'une certaine
façon complice de ça quelle est votre
réponse est important de donner votre
avis là-dessus puisque vous êtes
interpellé
moi je pense que c'est important qu'ils
retournent en espagne mais mais au-delà
de ça je vous dis moi les premières
manifestations que j'ai fait sous manuel
valls c'est une amie qui se casse le
coude à la suite d'une charge de police
c'est un autre ami qui se prend une
grenade de désencerclement dans la jambe
et qui finit à l'hôpital pour ça avec
des plaies assez profonde c'est ça le
bilan politique de manuel passé et sa
gestion policière
donc ce n'est pas une guerre des rares
c'est un état qui fait la guerre à son
peuple c'est ça comme ça a commencé
avant mâcon maintenant c'est encore le
cas mais je vous dis je vous le redis
quand vous avez plus de policiers sur
une manif de soignants soi-disant nos
héros un jeu à dix jours pour eux pour
encadrer de sanchez ya un souci voilà
jeu et si et si ça si ça paraît absurde
aux jambes à moi je vous je continuerai
à le dire il ya un souci dans la manière
dont on traite et manifestations
notamment à paris mais pas que et la
manière dont on traite notre peuple le
fait payer des infractions et je le
répète le fait qu'il y ait des
infractions dans une manifestation
ça appelle une réponse proportionnée et
aujourd'hui cette proportion n'existent
plus parce qu'il ya une doctrine de
maintien de l'ordre qui fait qu' on
envoie des crs parfois au casse-pipe
charge et au milieu de tout le monde ce
qui fait que tout le monde est touché au
lieu de toucher uniquement les
manifestants je dis pas que c'est ça
mais il ya quelque chose qui bug dans le
dans la doctrine de maintien de l'ordre
et puis dernièrement et c'est aussi une
des choses il ya aussi des policiers qui
doivent comprendre que parfois ils sont
pas obligés de céder à la pression et
qu'il ya des images qui choque par
exemple on traîne pas quelqu'un par les
flancs manifestation même si elle
achetait des cailloux même si
l'interpellation peut se comprendre on
la traîne pas par les cheveux dans les
bois voilà on arrive à la fin mais je
voudrais quand même que didier justement
parce que c'est important martinez vous
répondre sur ce point s'est blessé des
gens
voilà qui ont perdu des yeux qui se sont
blessés qui sont tirées par les cheveux
ces images là est ce que vous voulez
déploré didier martinez écoutez il faut
toujours faire quand même la part des
choses entre ce qu'on appelle la
violence
j team de l'état plutôt que d'analyser
systématiquement toute offensive
policière commettant des violences
illégitimes l'autorité lorsqu'elle
s'exerce lorsqu'elle sa vie qu elle est
toujours dans le cadre de procéder à des
interpellations ou défendre des intérêts
qu'il s'agisse de bâtiments ou de
personnes pour ce qui est de dijon ça a
été cité et les violences qui sont
commises je m'aperçois que le dispositif
a été fortement calibré dans les jours
qui ont suivi
mais quand j'entends ici ou là qu'il
faudrait désormais la police enlevaient
des policiers enlevés des effectifs et
qu'on voit la configuration aujourd'hui
du pays
avec cette violence et la montée en
puissance de la délinquance de la
criminalité est ce que subissent les
forces de l'ordre au quotidien je
m'interroge aussi sur la nature de la
sécurité publique on pourra monter à
notre situation
j'avais vraiment envie de passer on a
l'air on est à la fin du débat j'avais
eu deux disques qui a dit qu'il fallait
baisser les effectifs de police pas nous
et deuxièmement moi je pense que ce
qu'il faut désormais c'est parfois
l'imbécillité parce que vous voyez quand
vous avez des syndicalistes policiers de
chez vous qui vous disent que
c'est une ancienne convenable ou yves
lefebvre qui me dit qu'un manifestant
qui se fait arracher sa main c'est bien
fait pour sa gueule et ça c'est votre
secrétaire général qu'il dit en désarmé
déjà des commencé par affirmer votre
cerveau messieurs parce que il ya aussi
un problème dans certains syndicats à
tout accepter
au point que les choses les plus les
plus les plus basiques soit soient
soignés par certains syndicats et ça
c'est dommage de votre part parce que
vous avez une responsabilité pour
appeler au calme aussi
merci merci à tous les dieux didier
martinez david guiraud d'avoir accepté
ce face à face